Welcome back and thank you for your interest in learning more about
world building for virtual production.
In this class, we'll review our agenda for the upcoming lessons,
and then we'll take a look into derived data cache and its importance.
As I just anticipated,
in this first module we'll explore derived data cache.
We'll be starting out with some ground theory on it,
understanding what DTC is,
its different types,
and where it's located and how to change that.
Once the theory is covered and out of the way,
we'll be ready to dive into world scopes and initial setup.
We'll be exploring different ways of dealing with a project,
breaking it down into shocks and assets,
and importing outside assets from libraries like Megascans or Fab.
And after that, we'll be uncovering some basic lighting concepts
and briefly talk about a very useful tool called Environment Light Mixer,
which is used to quickly set up our maps with realistic lighting.
Alright, spicing it up a bit,
we'll explore different approaches of editing assets,
whether using construction blueprints or blueprints in general,
procedural content generators, or modeling tools.
We'll also discuss about how to manage levels using the Stage Monitor
and increment them easily using the Level Snapshot tool.
Then we'll get an overview on materials
and how to use them efficiently using material instancing.
Lastly, we'll conclude this course by learning about the foliage tool
and we'll be getting a little nerdy checking out the profiling tool of the engine.
Cool, let's get started with some draft data cache theory.
First of all, in basic computer terms,
a cache is a small, fast storage area of your computer memory
where your computer temporarily keeps copies of frequently used information
so it can access that information much more quickly
than going back to the original source each time.
This is similar to keeping your most used items on your desk
rather than just storing them in a cabinet across the room.
In Unreal Engine terms, the draft data cache holds a very similar function.
DDC is like a smart finding system that saves your time when working with assets.
Imagine you have assets like textures or models
that need to be processed before the engine can use them.
Instead of processing these assets from scratch every time you need them,
Unreal stores the processed versions into DCC's.
When Unreal needs a processed asset,
it first checks the fastest, closest storage location.
If not found there, it checks progressively slower storage locations.
And when found, it copies that data to the fastest storage for quicker access next time.
If not found anywhere, Unreal processes it from scratch,
then saves it to all storage locations so it's available to you or your team in the future.
Now the DCC contains only 10 Ferrari copies
that Unreal Engine can just throw away and recreate whenever it needs them.
The original files are the U-Asset ones
and those contain all the important information.
So make sure not to delete them or just move them around.
Now this setup is really helpful because Unreal Engine can change
how it works with our assets without ever changing their original files.
Kind of like making different versions of a photo
without changing the original image itself.
There are two main types of DCC's.
The boot DCC, which consists of startup files
loaded into memory to increase boot times.
And then the local DCC, which includes the derived data for our projects.
If you're interested in learning about the different DCC types in depth,
I'd encourage you to follow the link in the slide down here
because it will provide you with all the information and specifics you need.
Let's jump into the engine for a moment to take a glimpse at the Zen server
and other cache statistics.
Alright, so if we take a look down here,
we can find the green check mark with Zen server written right next to it.
And the Zen server or the Unreal Zen storage is an EpicMate program
that manages our local DCC's separately from the main editor.
Now by default, when we launch the editor,
the Zen server automatically starts too.
And when we close the editor down, then the Zen server does the same.
And that's why we have this green check mark here.
All it says is that the Zen server is on.
Now if we click on Zen server, we get access to a few options.
The first one being the launch dashboard.
And if we launch it, we'll get an overview of how our Zen server is doing.
We can see that it is running on the engine version 5.6
and that the disk space that this project is occupying is 4.2 gigs.
Now under tools here, we have the option of stopping, restarting
or starting the Zen server if we wanted to.
And then we have something really useful down here.
We could actually launch a garbage collection process
and then free some unused disk space.
So this process will basically just delete some unused asset
and we can choose whether we want to just delete all the unused asset
or the asset we haven't used in a week
or the ones we haven't used in the past day.
And then our project will get lighter.
Okay, let's check out some few different options that we have down here.
So if I click on cash settings, we will go into the editor preferences.
We'll be able to change the global local DDC and shared DDC paths if we wanted to.
Or the individual project local and shared DDCs.
We will be able to enable all disabled notifications for the derived data cache
as well as enable or disable the AWS S3 cache.
And then we will be able to input the Horde server URL.
We would be using the Horde server if we needed help distributing build tasks.
So if we were building a game or a project across multiple computers in a theme environment.
Okay, what else do we have down here?
We have the cache statistics, which would tell us what's been loaded here in the project
and how it's working.
And then we also have the cache resource usage,
which would tell us how our resources are being used.
All right, let's go back to our slides and see how to set up shared DDCs.
So a shared draft data cache in Unreal Engine is a system where processed asset data
is stored in a central location that all team members can access, like a shared drive.
Instead of each person having to process the same asset individually,
which can take a long time, the first person processes it
and everyone else can use that same processed version.
By default, the editor is not set up to use a shared DDC
and instead each person's Unreal installation uses a local DDC stored in the wrong computer.
But we can easily enable shared DDC either by adding an override in the default engine
configuration file to set the path of the project to a shared location.
By setting an environment variable to the shared folder
or setting the shared draft data cache variable in the editor.
Now, in order to work together with a team on a single or multiple projects,
those projects would first need to be accessible by every member of the team
on their own individual computers.
Now, there are various ways of setting that up.
The simplest would probably be mapping a network drive on your local network.
This will allow you to share this mapped network or folder across your team
as long as they're connected to the same network as yours.
You can find further information at this link to understand how to do that in a Windows environment.
And a simple research online will let you find different solutions
for different operating systems too, like Linux or Mac OS.
All right, that was it for this class.
But you can find some additional documentation at this link
if you're interested in further expanding your knowledge in the RAP data cache
and mapped network drives.
Thanks for sticking around.
And in the upcoming lesson, we will look into world scopes and initial setups
when building our environments for virtual production.